pour nous le aux antilles ce sera une
catastrophe mais j'espère que les
français seront suffisamment éclairé
pour ne pas faire ce soit désagréable
pour nous est catastrophique pour tout
le monde je voudrais le pen ça fait deux
fois qu'on lui fait barrage pour la fait
barrage alors je souhaiterais qu'elles
soient vues quand même parce qu'on a
besoin de voir ce qu'il ya derrière
je ne suis pas du tout la politique je
suis super politique puisque je ne
m'intéresse pas du tout à ça si je suis
comme tout le monde je n'ai pas de
candidat précis pour le moment je
viendrai on a c'est encore moi les
présidentielles c'est dans deux mois ah
non pas du tout je ne vois pas dit non
les électeurs devront faire un choix
clair et net toute conscience à chacun
sa liberté absolue de conscience
et puis si marine le pen est élue
présidente
nous verrons et yul effet débarquer qui
a eu à mettet voulait tirer jusqu'à vous
aurez aussi passer par les balles non
non non non ce que je vais vous
déterminez vous suivez quand même
l'actualité les sondages le placent
marine le pen après position ça me passe
comme ça je dis la vérité je ne mens pas
à quoi bon le maintien
je vous remercie à les revoir